efforts to overhaul the NAFTA free-trade
agreement are entering a critical new
phase with the arrival of the Canadian
foreign minister in Washington today
President Trump and his outgoing Mexican
counterpart announced a preliminary deal
yesterday to replace the trade agreement
for the three North American countries
stocks hit record highs even though mr.
Trump threatened to place tariffs on
Canadian made cars if Canada does not
reach a deal The Wall Street Journal
editorial board writes this morning on
first inspection this is half a NAFTA
that contains some improvements but is
notably worse in many ways weather can
pass Congress is far from certain CBS
News business - Jill Schlesinger is here
Jill good morning good morning
a tentative agreement still not a deal
but the impact front page of USA Today
likely will mean higher car prices for
all Americans right because a part of
this plan is really to strengthen some
of the labor components of NAFTA so
there are two big parts of the
automobile sector that would be
influenced by this potential preliminary
deal the first is that 75% of a car's
value would have to be made in Mexico in
the US and that's basically a way to say
any Goods coming from China that passed
through Mexico can't backdoor their way
into the u.s. the other part is that
forty to forty five percent of car
components would have to be made by
manufacturers paying at least $16 an
hour
so imagine that that would raise the
costs for cars which would could
potentially be passed along to consumers
it also may actually can actually create
many jobs right so that could be good
but prices could go up but it also means
wages go up for those workers indeed I
mean wages go up either in Mexico for
those workers or here in the u.s. those
workers are already getting those wages
it's a way to prevent US companies from
sending those jobs to cheaper facilities
in Mexico what does it mean for trade
relations between the US and Canada
well this is a really interesting phase
and as we said in the intro the Canadian
foreign minister Chrystia Freeland is
actually in DC today this is going to
get heated Canada had two big beefs with
the United States they basically said
you deal with Mexico but there are two
issues we really care about we don't
want this whole deal to
sunset after five years the US had been
had said we want that to happen the
government already gave on that so in
the deal with Mexico it's a 16 year deal
to be reviewed every six years so Canada
is gonna be happy about that but there's
another part where the US has said we
don't want the dispute resolution to
take place as currently written they
kind of want to water it down and Canada
has said that's a No Deal for them so it
could get contentious here we really
want to see Canada participate we'll
call it NAFTA 2.0 which I think would be
an improvement for the US or The Wall
Street Journal calls that happen after
half and half what do you think about
that character well I think I just like
saying happen well I think the problem
is that until you have Canada signing on
this could get very thorny and having a
bilateral deal is not as good as a
trilateral deal remember US
manufacturers and industries they have
adjusted to this this has been in place
since 1994 they don't want to see huge
changes because they are already running
a business that actually can reflect
NAFTA these improvements could help some
losers will start squawking but again
the faster we get this done the better
it will be right to be continued for
sure thank you Jill always good to see
you